hi there this week it's another life
hacks episode Johnny and Youssef from
problem Fitness are joining me as we
originally intended to do a podcast
about relationships and we didn't even
get around to the topic so after an hour
of us all chatting [ __ ] we decided to
just do a life hacks episode
relationships will be coming up and I
might actually enough people are
interested
I might just post the hour and a bit of
what we ended up talking about coz is
actually pretty funny under ection 'el
but quite interesting coming up soon
I've got Corey Allen from the astral
hustle podcast also the creator of
release into now which is my favorite
guided meditation actually sitting down
with him tomorrow and I'm going to be
going through from beginning to
developing your practice in meditation
how mindfulness can be for everybody I'm
also sitting down with Quinn hanok from
juggernaut training systems to go
through some mobility myths and work out
to try and cut through some of the
[ __ ] about what
mobility stability and flexibility mean
in a performance perspective and I've
managed to get Johann Hari author of
lost connections recently on Joe Rogan's
podcast and an absolute intellectual
monster I might should get him to say
yes to come on so I can't wait to sit
down with these guys feeling really
fortunate but before that obviously
biggest guests that I could have Johnny
and Yusuf from propane Fitness let's go
what makes me laugh about that
Continental place is the fact that the
quiet as far in all of Newcastle that's
both in terms of customers and volume
coming out of the speakers surprisingly
quiet for customers yeah and through the
back
is a room which is even more private and
quiet
yeah that's it's almost eerie why what's
this graveyard
room at the back for whose idea was it
to put this here why is it still here
yeah
how is this place why the Pens in my
wine the desks laid out like a 1940's
example and why are they only hire
Spanish people mmm but it's quite cold
continental isn't it so they have to
make it authentic but they give you a
little bit just a poor I got into my
I've never admitted steak I just have
things that kill him oh yeah peanuts
they give you like a little meatballs
often pork or peanuts actually so okay
so they're either a sacrilege or fatal
yeah two people in our friendship with a
cover on it so I for iveco [ __ ] anyway
life hacks we're gonna be life Act one
of three Johnny is delirious after a day
of playing God expend the three No
[Music]
would you believe do you believe of all
of the things that you do all of the
things that you put your body for its 25
to 11 and you've wrecked off swinging
swinging around I mean what's it what a
golf good way
no that's not hard three kids are hard
it's the walk yeah it was a list this is
the list
it's the Napa the need so many terms for
it you saw the guy in the news recently
who was given pregabalin for pain and
claims that it made him gay and then his
dad stepped into the newspapers and said
he's always likes boys so what's marine
jungle in here well this brig of Luther
just a painkiller for neuropathic pain
but like I mean it definitely is not
listed on the side effects that makes
you gay there is that there is no it
wouldn't no question that well unless he
is the first recorded case of it but
then I love how it stops on order or
guys come on the road he's always liked
boys got drums all week on the topic of
people being scared straight or scared
gay we did mrs. Empress this week where
two of our event managers dressed up as
women for charity men's prostate cancer
raises money for that so I meant or not
that money raised that five grand raised
in the night prayin and we've got a guy
who works for us who's gay and upon
seeing one of our event managers come
out dressed as a woman he said that he'd
being scared straight said I don't like
boys anymore
so you know that all these I pray the
gay away camps in America but I'll need
the Skadden strengths pray the gay away
you know seen these know that the
priests that have clearly gave
themselves but just projected they're
projecting I feel like the power of
Jesus to make you straight dragged women
like the norm is like
all they'll cost me as well so I watched
an episode of Family Guy
while Lauren Conrad from the hills is on
it and she says we've heard it's all
part of a big publicity stunt at the
moment they're actually CG eyeing a sex
tape of me and Bill Cosby and it's Bill
Cosby like undressing like two years
later that could not be any more
inappropriate hmm CG eyeing that she
said that they were see Jonah at sex
tape of her in him but this is before
all of the [ __ ] came out but bill haha
it's so partly that's gonna become a
thing soon that we're not going to be
able to use video evidence as a
procedure yeah it was a thing like that
so must be a bit on Facebook you'll be
fake news probably yeah but they let me
look there was a guy there was a video
of Barack Obama speaking saying like
really weird shows like Donald Trump is
a clearly a [ __ ] yeah and then it
splits the screen and it's got the guy
who's actually doing the voice ah many
are completely completely CGI'd
apartment like right isn't [ __ ]
mental but somehow his touches on that
right with the ham Cyrus thing like this
MEA does made a version of me on the
internet so I completely support it you
don't support it I take a humorous
version of my and but but it's clear
lots of very good impression ridiculous
but II do but it's not it's not it's too
fast but if you listen to it one and a
half times it was very like yeah he's
just so it's as if so beginning the
podcast and I'm gonna talk about
something I'm very boring for a real
long time that's getting housekeeping
sam harris i have Sarah's right
lifehacks 103 max first one I've got
I've been killing as good so I've been
writing some in on a daily basis we've
had the ones that were like apps and
stuff so fun what I've been doing is
I've been using like a no as a like a
life hack diary of stuff that I do and I
think he does a lot cast well so first
one I've got wouldn't follow the people
that you hate from social media and both
of you are culprits of not doing this
mmm not really name the plethora of
people yeah it's interesting
if so the thing is there's a lot of
pleasure out of following the people
that even hate or is it's just like a
car crash it's entertainment but it's
but it's not because you come away from
it a lot of the tunnel at indignant
truth it was David's analysis of it like
she's got she's passing she's got the
door to print to assume that she's
passing often was it cheap she's passing
off what is offensively obvious
wisdom got the arrogance - yeah it's
good follow the people that you hate
like you could especially on Facebook
you don't need to unfriend them
interests and follow unfollow your
profile as well yeah 30 days in a break
so flirt with the profile icon here
click on friends click on and follow
you'll never have to see this stuff
again and that is for one of a better
term if you're not good if someone's not
in the same cities you one following
someone Facebook is tantamount to them
dying never gonna see them again okay
I'm never gonna see them again unless
they comment on something that you
comment on as well um but the following
people on Instagram is a little bit more
tricky because every time that I think
about it for ages and then eventually
decide to do it I do it to the tiny
minority of people you have these
[ __ ] on follow checkers set oh oh
they message you why did you and follow
me yeah well why do you care yeah I got
it's I've heard like it's happened three
times in last year really I mean that
it's lame like you called them out on it
now which is great but like to get the
hint if someone follows you and you and
you've got something to check that as
well but you should take it gracefully
you shouldn't you shouldn't follow the
PPTA like I know there's definitely a
cathartic pleasure from watching a car
crash of someone else's life go on for
someone who you kind of love to watch
what they're doing but you also kind of
don't at the same time it Nets a
negative bottom line is it nets and now
you didn't you are right we are in we
are in the midst of battling against
phone use like talk about the medium do
you that you're doing it through its
yeah it's very much a guilty pleasure
that I like there are life following car
crash basic [ __ ] and seeing you're
right like they're it's a net negative
thing there's no enrichment of my life
and so I think in that's a positive I
know I always do this I'm like I'm the
Jeremy Clarkson of these discussions I
suppose it has to be otherwise it
wouldn't continue doing it I disagree so
it's bad for you all the time it's the
buyer and Katie approach to it okay you
know buying it you know the book I was
gonna give you the Nova gave you this is
one that you said changed your life or
anything it never told me about until
asked you yeah yeah
so here argument is is that anything we
used to froze this far more if I'm more
dealer and only but things that bother
you are a chance to investigate why
apology and try and uncover a deeper is
most the time like so like realistically
something that someone is doing over
social media like yes it bothers you
like it might be because they're really
cheap ended or basic or like have said
to me you don't agree with but that is
usually just something internal with you
and it is it a chance I find to like
that's really [ __ ] me off why has that
really [ __ ] me off and you always see
some another side of it from going
through her process but that is like
taking LSD going up
trip seeing the other side of it hmm
going interesting introspective
experience that I really should go away
and reflect on what's going on mm-hmm
and then everyday for the rest of your
life just taking more LSD
going back to the same place it's the
same person I see what you mean
so I think the point is is that you get
exposed to annoying things anyway and
like social media is just a would you
would like to do that so I think if you
can get to the point where it bothers
you less then great cool so until up
until the point at which it plateaus
we've managed to try and come up with a
way to use following annoying people
online for a source of personal develop
well you know that's gonna be flipping
and flipping a negative on its head I
think if something bothers you and it's
someone else doing something it's
probably you not them more than likely
if that they're not you said what do you
think are there nobs I think is what it
but why do you think they're not the
first [ __ ]
but it is because they're doing
something that I guess maybe they're
doing something this direction they're
polluting something that triggered me
well there's something to be said for
like but if something triggers you it is
attempt to be a pointer to something in
yourself I don't know whether it applies
100% at the time because I could think
of things that would like you can think
of things that would trigger you but
what don't have any kind of deeper truth
there just knowing bell Jenko getting
caught up in traffic
yeah is annoying for the sake of it
occurring yeah I don't think it reveals
much about you it
no no truce and right well it shows you
have a belief that I shouldn't get a co
in traffic which is far worse because
you do get caught up in traffic I visit
that's an interesting one about why
we're so angry about in cars it's
because of the heightened sense of
awareness because we're not used to
going at that speed even exactly yeah
it's always that it's always like look
if you know you're not paying attention
we're not you couldn't lend us both
people died in cars that's why I'm if
there we go on so I can't remember if I
mentioned this last time but this ties
into the capture process but I think you
have to always have so with me you know
20 years ago it would be carrying a
notebook in your pocket
the pockets and every fire the facts by
the facts and if something comes into
your awareness that needs to either be
action or looked up or noted down or an
insight or something it would go down in
the notebook and when you get home you
would then put into it put it into your
process which is like you look through
your notebook at the end of the day be
like right I've got these things these
need to be either put into the action
list or whatever and so for me Toby
which is a browser extension for Chrome
allows me to quickly organize anything
so if someone sends me an article that I
need to read or there's a video comes up
that I should watch at some point or
whatever and I can't action it right
away I can create separate queues of
reading queue listening queue and then
frequently visited thing and then you
can sub split those into like for me for
example it would be medicine study
propane or business stuff and then work
that needs to be done and so having that
as a capture means that you can no
longer lose out on someone sends you an
article uh I'll read that later because
it's very subtly it's a very cleverly
put together bookmarks manager isn't
it's great we did we did actually bring
this up on the last one however you've
done you've come out from a different
angular which I think that's worth what
I think so because this um you know you
can try and capture it at the point of
at the point it comes in but then you
have no control over whether someone
sends you a what's up or a text message
you'll speak it you're speaking about
this a little bit in the way that a 10th
dan black belt we've talked about
punching someone in the face I do think
I do think that you're totally right
that you need to we are stressed by
having too much stuff that we need to
remember our brains are built for
processing information not remembering
information right exact decision-making
not retention it's built for having
thoughts and holding them okay at all so
there's a couple of layers there and one
of them is the decision that you use
that darn you open a new tab you like I
want to read something if you have to
make a decision ever
time or run through any obviously you
can't mark your eye messages as unread
for example or whatever so it's a very
so you have to then be like right I
don't need to read something
are there was that thing that Chris sent
me a couple of weeks ago and also
whereas instead if you have the reading
queue you just pick the first thing in
that queue you decision for you one of
the problems is that a lot like 85% of
people's browsing is now done on mobile
and you can't get Toby from or about to
be on you've gotta be on laptop it's so
you guys who mobile you can get pocket
which is similar but that's just from
using like one Evernote I suppose as
well but
yeah I mean to be honest I I think
mobile browsing is an absolute fool's
game 85% of you who were listening right
fools don't know about I don't think I
read I don't think I would ever do
sitting browse
it's normally listen listen positive
right I could do one that I've been
experimenting with research that it's
more of like a is it Nova no and this is
something that I speak to a lot of
clients about who struggle with just
training getting their training in I
think it's the case with try to do
anything that you want to do
consistently so used to train for days a
week done that like for as long as I can
remember started finding that I'd have a
particularly hard session or like
schedule would be slightly different and
I just go on trend tomorrow and then it
gets to Friday and you realize that you
want to train for those of trophies
right you want to trade Friday Saturday
Sunday you know right well that's gonna
rack me and I was starting to get
niggles and so I was just like right I'm
just gonna try and train six days a week
stay the same volume shorter sessions
and just part of my morning is get up do
morning routine stuff go the gym start
work after that and doing that has been
really positive so far
so these are the four see what's what's
the main change
volumes stayed the same but spread
across more sessions yeah we're doing so
in short shorter sessions is less of a
there's less of a barrier to like oh my
god I'm going to be in the gym for two
hours each of the sessions it therefore
easy in a slightly lower impact yeah
you've had time presumably got to get
your coach to adapt to sign it off here
yeah the program so he I think he has
probably up the volume ever so slightly
there's a few more assistance exercise
let me say it would be silly not to
right yeah but it it's just because
before that yeah well the way that I
operated anyway was
today's training day tomorrow's a
training day today's a rest day yeah and
your whole routine is different yeah for
me anyway at the time I start working
right so it's a inherent inconsistency
yeah to your daily routine
yeah built into your daily routine aptly
built into your my daily routine and so
just especially during the week so I'll
still I still trying to take some day
off yeah if I can but didn't today I
like like I like it Sunday training
session it feels like an extra day that
I'm gaining that I probably wouldn't
have done wouldn't doubt yeah and I can
do like today I did 90 minutes wasn't
very fun dad didn't 90 minutes of rehab
and then been myself on what bike doing
intervals for 20 minute pages up and
that's when you terms of what I do in
the gym name yourself absolutely did
properly fully right myself that's
really interesting Abby I'd be very
interested to see what difference that
has on stuff like your metabolism like
fat loss yeah like that it I think and
that something else I've noticed is just
like yep you too maybe don't get it but
I live days were sporadically I wake up
and I just feel a bit more tired than
normal like a bit mentally fuzzy yeah
yeah if you just go train like over
you're pretty much like after a training
session I've pretty much reason others
saying today today was a perfect example
of that so last night a travel around
blog this week up 20 to 30 hours of
traveling I've done this week last night
went to Manchester at 9 o'clock
6 a.m. go up at 12:00 midday really
groggy but was like right usually on a
weekend I counted lettuce my routine
slip a little bit because it allows me
to come back on the Monday with a better
set of fresh eyes mmm didn't do it treat
you today like a Monday go up journal
meditate Rawat cook go to the gym and by
the time I had been myself on what bike
doing a really really horrible interval
workout I came out of the gym and there
was a sense of knowing his sense of
euphoria for the naturally get the
dopamine kick that you get from South
training but it was glazed with this
extra sense that I'd done it under a
particularly high level of fatigue and
I'd overcome a bunch of stuff that I
probably wouldn't have done usually
there was an extra an extra level of the
Falaise yeah yeah it was it was a veneer
of just extra little achievement and
niceness it was quite nice there was
there was two people really it was
something that you said about if you
having a bad if you feel like having a
bad day but you can't be bothered or
whatever look like if you go if you go
train you've kind of set the wheels in
motion of like I've already ticked off
something positive yeah and there's just
it's such a like a cringy thing to say
but there's something about like
sweating or doing something physical
when a daily basis here can feel it's
such a reset oh right I would I would go
as far as to say that going to the gym
and training is as much of a reset for
what has happened before then mmm is
going to tell you I went to bed is yeah
yeah definitely
I can I can wake up on the morning with
especially now I've been meditating more
recently and practice in a bit more
mindfulness
I find that my emotions from the night
before my thoughts from the night before
carry over through my sleep
mmm on average I only sleep six and a
half hours a night so that might be that
might come to be a little bit but I find
that they carry over a lot when I go
into the gym you can go in with a
terrible mood and come out come out I
mean it as much of a difference between
before and after as it is if
sleep hmm so yeah that's an interesting
since that and the most consistent
person I know with training is digital
audio broadcast Gibson so he trained see
dat hips Gibson I'm trading he just
traded six days a week like I do his
programming for him he trains 6:00 a.m.
Monday different way he trains 6:00 a.m.
Monday to Thursday
that's Friday off train Saturday Sunday
and he very very rarely lets his
traveling very greatest gift accession
house
he's like by 9:00 a.m. I've trained and
then like people who try and fit it in
in their day later yeah anything can
proc but it comes increasingly hard as
we were saying with meditation yeah the
more you try and convince yourself that
you can skip your morning session and do
it later on in the day the lesson that's
likely it is that you're gonna complete
it yeah he's a little who's make nice
dinner ah so you're the other thing to
consider as well is that once it's doing
the anxiety of having to do it is gone
for the res nothing that's a huge factor
but ironically that's like that's that's
the main reason that I meditate on the
morning because I know that for the rest
of the day I don't need to think I need
to meditate stuff don't you feel like I
think it for me as if there's a sense of
like I've I've kind of one that I
started my life like I via the box the
box has been taken yeah one already that
was another reason why this sobriety the
six month sobriety thing to me was such
a keystone mmm when I did it because I
was facilitating I saw yeah for sure
because it meant that I could overcome
right already I've already conquered
this one's next what's coming next on
the list so yeah yeah was a just it's so
nice to get to like if I get to like
half 9:00 or 10:00 a.m. and I've done
like meditative rawad or stuff and I've
trained and it's like that's yes like me
out the way like now I can just work and
I'd have to worry about anything else
and when I finish work I'm done like I'm
sorry so you don't yeah and you just
feel and the thing is as well especially
for me your training probably wouldn't
this because with powerlifting you need
to give yourself more time to rest and a
little bit more taxing I guess
physiologically but for me if I do that
and I think right six o'clock what I
want to do
that's another session can we go back in
I'm gonna do extra programming I'm gonna
do workout I mean do bodybuilding salt
work after he crossed that this morning
I'm gonna go and do some technique work
and go and do that
it's bonus yeah mmm and you're like [ __ ]
I'm not catching up yeah yeah you're not
playing catch up you you're getting
ahead which is yeah it's a there's a
really good sense of satisfaction think
a lot of people you know if there's
anything that you need to do like if
it's [ __ ] walking the dog doing you
know spending time reading with you with
a kid mmm you know if that's something
that needs to be done crank it out there
get it cracked up so that you know that
the box has been ticked it's the rest of
the day's yours though because then the
rest of the day you're not thinking
where am I going to be like that anxiety
is so it's it's so interesting taking
the same session so if I do it right if
I try and train it like for for example
or 9mm if I train at 9:00 knowing like I
need to get to work but I don't you
start work soon what you're able to do
in like you immediately arrest periods
of ice hockey's and small busy yeah you
don't look at your phone you're in
you're out you know [ __ ] I did there's
training 45 minutes
yeah like normally piss around and takes
ages so yeah I used to do when I worked
at KPMG I did it all the time like I
always trained in the morning but I have
such bad memories of it because it was 6
o'clock in the morning it was all KPMG
yeah well yeah but it was so it was that
and then I had to Joe had to like as
like an hour-long commute and was always
a really hard training as well so but a
little bit later go drive to the gym is
rush hour train name it's really if you
take big fun of course
no everyone can do that bit realize I've
just taken the microphones I'm sorry -
next one Apple Airport oh God
that's so good I know audio broadcasts
Fossum I say yeah digital first audio
broadcast you early so they are without
a doubt that you said this before single
biggest change in quality of life was
something that you came up with for one
of your last life hacks Apple iPods to
me ah from upon purchase quality of life
instantly increases on aggregate by five
to ten percent every day and upon using
them by 15 image by earning them it's
how nice they are and so you know what
makes them is lack of dental floss I
said little things about me but I'm not
small it but it's just everyone use
every needs pair of headphones um if
you've not you if you're not on iPhone I
don't know how they will link up where
nothing they can but they're just
bluetooth headphones right so mostly
they not have something in them because
wasn't that one of the criticisms of the
home pod I'm not sure it was it only I
wouldn't I wouldn't be able to maybe
that maybe they do work I would be able
to elaborate anyway if you if you are
someone who uses your headphones ever
you should buy pair of our pods or
something they come in a case the little
case is an external charger for the
earbuds the buds get four hours charge
out of about fifteen minute dog in the
external charger and the external
charger has about three full charges of
the boots yep the charger the external
case is plugged in with a lightning
cable so any other need to take one
cable away when you're on holiday or
when you're traveling is one for your
phone out the one for that they link it
with your phone instantly you can
program a double tap on the earbud of
the left to pause off from the right to
skip to the next track they've got in
but microphones at the bottom of the
earbud so that you can use them for
wireless hands-free they don't actually
I don't think they actually use
bluetooth to them either I think it's a
different kind of technology yeah I can
and NFC is it male for
communication is something different
about them so if you don't have if you
don't have a brick wall in between you
I've done the entire site before and I
can be 12 meters away I can be on the
opposite side of the hole and itself
crystal clear communicator I thought
this morning yeah I always think about
this more than I probably don't wherever
you want and yet like you you're walking
around in the house especially if you're
taking phone calls and stuff like that
a phone call actually ends up stopping
whatever else you do mm-hmm whereas with
these you can have headphones in yeah do
the washing up do your cooking they've
got nice counseling in so the person on
the other end here's just what you're
saying they are unbelievable the one
caveat for this is they're expensive
one hundred and sixty quid hunting for
year they are their expense they are but
they're worth it by soul so at myath
I've had like Bose headphones and I've
never heartbeat they're kind of like the
other competitor on there yet
are there like cheaper headphones and
nothing has come anywhere near but it's
not like I think what what I don't feel
like I've people turn off and oh my god
160 quid or whatever but it's the it's
how effortless and using them is take
one out pauses the music put it back in
again so if you since our podcast put it
back in again it recognizes that you
paused it jumps it back a second place
plays it again presses play I thought I
get in the car so if I'm on the phone in
the car like phone's on the blue tea to
the car before I get out the car air
pods out hit my ear pods in phone still
in my pocket get out the car
somehow the air pods realize hold on the
phones to take it back off of the heart
he wants the power back or how about
this how about this fee so I get in my
car and my car automatically picks him
up so I'm listening to a podcast amania
phones game of the car and starts
playing in the car yeah then all that I
need to do is double tap the earbud and
it will flick back off the car and back
into the earbuds unbelievable it's
because because what what someone Apple
has done has thought what does what are
the daily situations people with
headphones face yeah let's make air pods
good for that yeah that they are without
doubt absolutely fantastic so I honestly
think right obviously like the return
yet from
but in an iPhone is way beyond that but
in terms of like an accessory from a
whole unreadable it's yeah [ __ ] all over
an Apple watch absolute all yeah
definitely well it did they are they're
just so so good
Jordan today he was showing me so I
walked in with our pods in and went over
and like signed it and said hello and he
said like is there anything playing and
then were you swearing look look trendy
as I am actually listening but it is a
problem when you're not listening to
something yeah yeah the hood isn't and
he was like aha but mind you is that's
why I do so I didn't realize sit I sit
my foots on the top of my yeah with it
with the wider bit behind that's it and
if you listen as if he is if Jordans
told you that he gives me so much [ __ ]
for putting on top of my really busted
anyway airports you should buy them now
you mean behind the ears so if you
imagine that this sit on top of you you
like you would with a cigarette I mean a
nicely sustained they stare that wedged
in have you tried using the air pods
case as an iPhone holder
it's very precarious it ignites see so
if you google it there's examples of
people doing it so like if you found
yourself on a train or a plane and you
wanna watch them on your phone partially
open the air pods case sit your phone in
it and it does let go
sits back and then you've got your ad
pods in society that says it was a guy
using it doing in a cafe just before I
owned any and that like they came out as
I got a [ __ ] a stupid and it look like
you've got to oral-b to exactly as you
start eating with his phone in the
corner of the things in the airport
occasions Airport it was like that looks
so [ __ ] baller
any he had an iPad Mini as well I was
like that man likes apples to try and
like fit in with
is that the path version they are so
just so that's so prohibitively
expensive but you're right like me I I
thought that was a good chance for me to
go to the toilet because I don't have
nothing to contribute about air pods so
they don't have them but the the
hands-free calls alone I think would
sell me on the mum believe floor and
that did you know what's even cooler
that you guys did the other day and
everyone is gone like so the on the
propane Instagram
there was a multiple stories basically
like a kind of a video podcast I guess
like a too many three-hour video podcast
split up into the 15-second stories so
is it Facebook live this young lady's
chain snaking Lee it takes ages it's an
app called cut story yeah that divides
it they have to individually upload them
her okay and they were walking down the
street and one hug the left and one had
the right and the sound quality is
matched from both so cool and it's just
isn't sick I obviously think if you were
if you're in a cafe and you needed [ __ ]
I've run into that Chris the trader guy
and like just randomly you're running
this morning we're desperate to think of
a pod can I take this here but kids are
my vessel record press record and the
other thing and you could you know like
loads at conference calls right you want
to speak like two people went on the
same phone call yeah right you say if
you got one yeah so this isn't a very
sexy one but I am currently dealing with
a lot of companies too many to keep
track of in terms of following up
responses and so on so what I do is I
have a list on wunderlist called waiting
for and if I've sent out a request to
these companies maybe maybe I've got ten
or twelve or on the code at one time I
just added to that list and then I know
that they're people that I'm waiting for
a response from okay alternatively you
can do it all within Apple Mail if you
use mail Butler or follow up them which
is Johnny's preference mail Butler
allows you to tag an email as you send
it you take a box on the email itself
that says remind me in two weeks and it
links it adds a reminder interrupter
reminders links to that particular sent
email
and then it cancels the reminder if you
can respond to that email just fantastic
yeah
again what what we're talking about is
just capture isn't it means you can
really it's just removal of having to
remember stuff yourself my reminders now
a Steiner backup so much because I'm
using them so much well it's all the
time cuz I think because I got
criticized for my uncle who is like you
say if you need to just rely on your
memory more stop being such a [ __ ] with
we're using relying on calendars and
things that's like that's fine for you
to say if you're retired and don't have
anything like what do is remember to get
the cat out try a medical degree I'm
running because well you get to the
point where it exceeds the capacity of
your memory or even if it doesn't even
if you have a internal system it's gonna
stress you out by having to maintain the
open loops whereas if it's just
completely out of your head
you know that I can just check the way
see I am and heard back from end power
yet okay of it the chase them up yeah so
there's two I'm really important coming
up to with that and it's you need to
practice the skill of capture I think
yeah I'm not a time when you fall into
me well cuz like everyone's had that the
experience were you start doing
something else and suddenly the thought
of like oh my god I was meant to do two
days ago I was meant to do that's a
horrible feeling
Oh jarring it's like falling that's your
brain going like haha [ __ ] but you
didn't you didn't process this at the
time now so there's that that side of
its you need to practice it but also if
you just build up lists and you never
huh don't have like a time in the day
where you look at them then it's also
meaning but then when you look at your
list three days later captured it and
then you don't have a capture for the
capture yeah you just don't you just
pushed it somewhere else you like I look
at it later something that a guy called
the guy that we were told my early re
myzel yeah talks about to-do lists or
correctly managing your flow of things
is about reminding yourself of the thing
you need to do at the time you need to
be reminded so like he's big on using
email
there's an inbox so I get sending
yourself an email on Monday morning when
you know that on Monday morning you need
to do thing rather than write it on a
list and hope I'm a hope on Monday
morning you look at your you look at the
list because I think she's an argument
for having notifications off on your
phone apart from the ones that you have
reminders yeah
the thing is maybe you - you know I
think you've mentioned this before where
like something pops up like a
notification like a reminder pops up in
your bra ya can't do it now
snooze or like oh just [ __ ] off release
D just get a get away yeah and then it's
not like there's not you haven't dealt
with it so it pops up again or yeah yeah
I've tried to stack the deck in my favor
now so I have as much in the reminder on
on my iPhone and also my like laptop as
possible so if I need to follow a link
or send an email to someone it has the
email address of the person have you
ever done the opposite where you
absent-mindedly create a reminder I've
done this to myself quite a few times
now where you don't wanna come up on
your phone and it just says Friday 7:00
p.m.
[Laughter]
anxiety just to allow me to turn up to
12 how about this so I use Siri a lot to
do reminders and what I'll do is I'll
set a reminder on on Friday
remind me to email Santander about my
current account mm-hmm did you okay I'll
remind remind you on Friday I did it a
bit right brilliant don't look at it put
it away remind it comes back up series
bastardized my little bride sent to
something which is completely
incomprehensible yeah
remember the donuts are frying in the
kitchen or something and you
what is that
so much as well it's a serie series
great for when you're driving I think
yeah so the number of things that are
kidding me while I'm driving you know
it's great with what I thought I've here
see I like just saying hey Siri hey sir
hey Siri and then it just captured it
and I'll be listening what we're saying
is no it's okay it's okay
so Kepler existing all the time isn't he
yummy stuff like this is a three-person
podcast not for voice I've got but then
I don't know I also don't have a
girlfriend
you can set it on South African accent
Raimondi I'll remind you right I've got
one you seem mad lymphocytic room before
if there's a Peppa supercilious there
must be have I said oh yeah I've ever
mentioned Pomodoro's yeah before yeah
but you can if you if you can wrap them
in a different twist either focus me Pro
it's a mock-up might be a iphone up as
well the problem I so Pomodoro's focus
me all afternoon so what I recommend to
you is the same one okay the one line
you've got you've got a pro version
which means you have to pay for it which
it's a one-off which means that he
definitely hasn't yeah I've got be
focused free right right right
how's all the ads on so here what it
marks you reminders Pomodoro she is
is 25 minutes of work followed by five
minutes break and the idea is like to
prevent you from procrastinating like at
the start at 25 minutes you're like I'm
going to do this for 25 minutes and I'm
going to challenge myself to see if I
can do it for 25 minutes but I guess it
can't be that hard it really difficult
to do to try and manage your
distractions as 25 minutes of like
purely just doing whatever doesn't
matter what it is five minutes of total
disconnection and then you do that four
times then you get a longer break so
that's it that's how the Pomodoro set
was a bit how new colonising yeah it's
practicing deep work there's practicing
getting better at like just focusing on
one thing there's loads of case studies
of people using it and talk about how I
used to work a 60-hour workweek and now
I do
Aipom hours a day because I've become
better up with Parkinsons Laura's yeah
so having the power of having your
deadlines the power of having like a
timer counting down you know I've got to
finish this one thing in this time so
I've tried doing it on and off for ages
always found that like apps are pretty
like clunky or annoying or like you
forget to set on your phone or whatever
the app that whatever it's called
focused me you will be focusing I love
it is really simple and quite
unintrusive you just start it at the
start of the day and it just runs you
Pomodoro's for you just goes be reviewed
alright little bit yeah and then it also
it just shows its own
I love graphs and [ __ ] as you probably
notice it shows you so you keep a to-do
list we keep a list of all the things
you would normally do on any any time so
like start the day open click on the app
lit long list of things like what I'm
gonna do all right that one
press play starts Pomodoro and then
tracks it as when you want to look at
like how am i spending my time give you
a pie chart of how your time spent may
give you a bar chart harmony Pomodoro to
your day she like was it a productive
week and you think well I don't know
probably you know here's how I spend my
time
how's happy well medoras it it
which and it's so like I'm a big fan of
things that just to Fitbit
like I don't have to think about like
how is my sleep aha yeah generally after
my my it's just a collecting up yeah
since this is the same thing
so really the Pomodoro Technique and
that up what we want which one's the one
that you use Joey can you know I thought
it was focused well but it'll be in
it'll be in the description it's
something pro right it probably is be
focused Pro because there is a focus
mini war line it will fire Annesley some
seasoned disabled young one someone you
tell have a template you can use another
one which is probably a little bit more
of a prohibitive prohibitive life hack
but is one that I'm going to distinctive
for the rest of my life
automatic cars gearbox oh my god so I
told you about porn lots more talking
about this no so there's a guy who's a
bit of a facebook personality Paul
Turner who I was talking to him about
this topic and he was like oh yeah
people oh I said I'm [ __ ] I'm a
[ __ ] woman for driving off mic
alright then we'll take that's the
extreme Oh like I'm gonna crank up the
engine at the start and pump up my tires
every time and and spray water on the
windscreen here ladies like where does
it stop and you're like yep totally
agree that why is it that changing the
gear on the transmission is somehow the
manly thing to do akin to being involved
in the driving experience
yeah when someone will get out and go on
by a barista made coffee yeah as they
take the escalator in the lift you are
this is something like are they using if
I can i phone or like it's just one
minute so it's fine because I changed
gear manually here yes totally
yeah it's a it's I had to drive the
money all the other day and I realized
how much of a bore like it is when you
go back to it and it delays you like cuz
I get put really pissed off like
unreasonably annoyed
sorry Chris and I'm stealing your room
with I know that we only grain I might
as well as we might as well have all
said it I'm just very passionate about
it said like I get really annoyed at
people that take ages when the light
goes green mmm I think it's incredibly
and considerate to like wait for the
light to go green and then like slowly
get you ass into gear literally to to
pull off well I realize that what I was
saying about like okay it's gonna amber
right Mirror Mirror Mirror okay
handbrake Neutron clutch first pro-1
person through yes like so really
inconsiderate
but I realized that actually it takes
two or three times as long
yeah Mon you need to be prepared yeah
yeah we've all these that maybe pay
there's so much more I suppose maybe
this there's an argument that you're a
little bit more of a conscious driver
and you're probably a little bit more
alert during drive manual mmm just gives
me more involved in driving experience
you are more involved in the driving
experience but I will never ever go back
to having a manual car ever absent I
would I would happily leave the love of
my life if she demanded that we have to
have money and so I've just give it a
car be like I'm getting my own car a
recent recent change for me getting more
Mike
well humanism some yeah great massive
massive shift a Khloe feels like you're
driving a little dungeon doesn't this
like it well it just feels like I'm
driving a machine rather like where as
free with a manual it's like riding a
bike yeah we as pride ego thing they're
like oh I don't I mean I chanting I
don't see that I don't really see that
argument so much online anymore I just
think it's people who maybe haven't
listened to life hacks 103 and realized
that they minutes to buy it you need to
buy an automatic car tomorrow if you
have a manual car go change it no trade
it in if the girls are still making who
the [ __ ] who the [ __ ] was to me like I
don't know because I don't buy new cars
man but that doesn't really seem to be
much of a disparity there's a disparity
in the availability but not disparity in
the price so you can find an equal model
both manual and automatic so it's not
like I said premium luxury
no but there are fewer automatics around
and this certain cars that you cannot
get if you want a defender there's a lot
of people do the only way you'll get an
automatic defenders if someone to custom
change the transmission in the gearbox
is that presumably that's something to
do with like it's a for off-roading and
I'm not sure why would that be the case
I could do any do not like gearbox is
gonna be able to control the ratio of
modulator of much more effectively than
you can yeah with your right foot but
yeah just like by not money car as new
petrol efficient as well now didn't used
to buy it doesn't buy this yeah change
gear at the right there and if you want
to go faster I've just put your foot now
often it is used in sport mode yeah so
every cut every cars got go slightly
quicker mode when you're in an automatic
even if it's not you seen the tesla bird
i believe there's a ludicrous limit
reach back I was hidden it's up in the
the Roadster I didn't it's in order
there in the peep the P 100 D and
welcome to Piedmont you deep there yet
frightening
Lucas deliver to feed the rest against
the back of your rib cage you should
watch online the Tesla Model 3 which is
the family SUV one with the gullwing
doors mm-hmm so they were trying to
convey just 145 grand as well yeah if I
suddenly SUV yeah yeah really yeah it's
pretty expensive boots
[ __ ] mental it's unbelievable so they
were trying to convey just how quick
this car was to put it on a track and
they were like we've been doing these
tests for ages and no one can really
understand just how fast and powerful
this car is so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna put it on a track against an
Italian sports car and they've got a
Alfa Romeo spider pulled it next to it
like [ __ ] quick light Italian sports
car rapid says and it's gonna go up
against a Tesla Model 3 pulling a
flatbed with an Alfa Romeo spider on the
back oh man so the Tesla please II said
love taking it home I'm in quarter-mile
pulling the car that it's beating yeah
I've seen that video have you seen the
one where there's a guy parked it's in
like London or something as a guy with a
Lamborghini he like comes in parks
one of these a Tesla TVs that has a
show-off button you see the doors come
up it's gonna like everyone is ignoring
a lot easier taking it slow it's like
this that's that side of what you want
musk does it's just like class it's just
let's forget about the logistics of it
let's make Sun doesn't do it
stupid and have you seen when you press
the Ludacris button on it it says like
put some warnings up like this will
cause extended wear on the battery and
the tires and the transmission are you
sure yes no I want my mommy does that
clip of the I think it's the new
roadster that they've not released yet
it's like two seconds where they put it
into fast mode or never there's a
journalist in it and the screen goes
like I was like orange bike like like
laser yeah yes itself Drive yeah yeah
it's older than myself Drive have you
seen whether anything why the guy is
seated whether lorry driver seat no
there's one single seat directly in the
center of the cockpit he's just feel our
ego is rocket I'm gonna cope I'm going
to tag one at the end of automatic cars
and it's fulfilled petrol tanks of for
full fuel tanks like the overhead costs
the time of peeling off from your
journey to go to the petrol station mmm
is something that needs to be
apportioned across as Y as much profit
as possible and that overhead cost needs
to be apportioned across you filling
your tank to push the next trip to the
petrol station as far away as possible
money's prohibitive if you don't have
the cash to be able to fill your car
every time but if you do the extra like
saving yourself 30 seconds from not
holding on to the handle to fill the
tank means that you need to take three
to five minutes out of your journey one
week earlier then you would have done to
go back to the fuel station
the only Philips we've spoken about this
like countless times the only way in
which that's not the case is if teats
are two two situations I think one is if
you don't use your car that often but
you fill it up so like someone who's
just has like sixty quid of fuel sat in
that car for a long time okay okay you
can hide up well that neat well yeah
yeah it's the place of wealth like if if
you have a way if you are in some way
gaining interest from money that you own
okay then it's a cheaper target even if
you have that money in a suntan though
one two three account also which is the
highest level of interest that you're
gonna get you're on 1.5% a 60-pound well
no if you were like let's say you lady
the right thing ago like you this is the
some some thing you're doing to generate
returns from your car ok what's the
other
well this one the same thing so it's
like if you're if you're just always
filling up your tank you don't
necessarily need to like if it's not too
much of a detour to go to the petrol
station for example then I think so what
like what I do is fill up like some if I
know I've got a lot of driving today I
fill up so now I'm doing like what will
normally take me a week or we put half a
tank in but why not just put a full tank
in because it's not vanity preference
yeah because what I'd rather have the
cash in my bank account then what a full
tank just foresight that is the cut that
I I know how much cash I have but you
don't know how much cash is in your car
you know how much cash is in your bank
account okay
so trying to be visibility finally not
be creative and also yeah yeah it's the
analytics but you can't see a side from
that point
hmm I can't see any reason why I [ __ ]
petrol stations there are there are not
estimates as few despot future also so
thanks to you I filled up my car the
other day without having to get out of
it so so this is a little I can't
believe I can't believe that this is a
thing now so if you have cuu applepay
pre-authorized the amount that you want
to fill up so I say 60 pounds yeah and
then go to the car put in the petrol
thing take the cap and wedge that under
the handle and then get back in the car
and just sit for a bit until it's full I
don't know how that song go if you are
again so you know you unscrew the cap
you have you when you when you put the
nozzle in you squeeze the thing and then
you wedge the cap underneath it and it's
the perfect size to hold the thing as if
you were squeezing the petrol nozzle and
then rock it and say in your car so if
it's bad weather or if it's cold or
something you could just chilling any
car so he's saying without having to get
out of it you don't mean you have to get
out of it twice but for a brief time
right but if you paid at the pump right
yeah that's what I mean I don't have to
go to the kiosk I deal with close the
lid presumably the lids not does not not
to build it's definitely not built for
that you know thank know I carry a
tennis ball and wedge em to me I don't I
mean quite a bit I don't like having my
hand on it because it's covered in fuel
and it means the only right hand stick
visible for the rusty little gloves
doesn't it yeah the dude the dude you
little ghost I didn't think that's what
they were for it what do you think they
were fall to them just honey I believe
if account needed inseminating around
the corner in case you have to you know
cut some turkey for customer when you
have you have the gloves yeah isn't it
in the US don't they have people working
in petrol station let's do what they're
doing a lot places they're doing the UK
as well they do have the shell just down
the road and go so if they are really
but it's just yes I hit them peak time
no I seem to because I just to get
people through the dog but yet it will
be just like that they can just rather
people through but again that's a reason
to go a premium petrol premium fuel
station rather than going to like Tesco
well so I was just looking it up it
costs 3 pounds 64 to charge an electric
car or it's free and the public Chara
raison should probably
300 miles if you get good one so tell us
about give you a solar panel to put a
new garage and then it comes down like
the cable can come down plug it I'm so
sold on a Tesla
that's just like really expensive but
you can go and you can get a new one
that they can get Model S which is the
ones being run for a while you know the
saloon-style one there's some good ones
of that that's not super basic floating
around for about 60 grand now you think
like okay still it's still high end cars
and this is look what you get for it
yeah you do get an awful world so
spacious inside as well other massive so
it's a luxury car that's faster than
like 99% of things so if he's efficient
so cheap to run yeah like those nice one
or go one second harness pose I mean
even our ECP even on PCP gotta be five
grand down and recruit a month seven
hundred a month mmm maybe do a lot money
to pay for a car a bigger alternative
would be like that money you'd be
looking at like a three liter to the
diesel q7 like a nice q7 here thing like
that which is probably 500 quid a year
in tax yeah I'll save on tux on 60 quid
a fortnight yeah in fuel yeah yeah I'm
the fuel things the the Qi with them is
like I look well they've got like a
300-mile range you can get the absolute
top end once I think of the hundred D
yeah about 350 o of them which is the
one of the reasons I haven't seriously
look to the mix I can't what 100% got us
off to Manchester Mike yes that is you'd
have to find a Tesla charging point in
and that's what it's not if you're not
near one imminently you you really
that's what if it's not if that's only
going to become a less prohibitive with
time yeah so I think when the
infrastructure is fully in place that's
when laughing yeah absol diesel and
petrol just get phased out with it well
even I think it is it not all cars are
moving to diesel within the next stop
really all petrol yeah it's like diesels
getting phased oh is it hose of the
other way
yeah yeah silly little hybrid car or
something in the meantime and then
Oh for the best miss on leaf it's a leaf
mmm that's a 3-part 6000 I think that
pure electric the unloads of the that's
that there they get really precise
because of their workers their engines
or whatever it's not like something like
the engine creates the battery life
right so it's not like a tight you don't
plug it in yeah but as a sense of BMW i8
yeah yeah it is that's a hybrid right it
is yeah but a leaf apparently eats like
most sports cars of the first 20 meters
or so just as you get you can weigh
electric engines work yeah immediately
yeah which is why Tesla is so
frightening I mean have you ever have
you ever played Scalextric yeah like you
pulled it you pull the trigger and that
thing [ __ ] away yeah that's true it's
so like the those big articulated
lorries like if they are the cause you
seen how fast they go like fast is that
everything you know let me see the key
know where they pulling away the same
yeah later
oh it is yeah I mean it's gonna be
really interesting to see what happens I
suppose cause they're gonna have to have
a safety thing because it's very in
traffic you know like sometimes you you
glad that it doesn't pull off so fast
because you could have easily just yes a
car surrender so there's loads of Tesla
like self-drive videos of like Tesla's
avoiding avoiding collisions and so have
you seen there's a video that I saw the
other day of an s-class of the s-class
Merc it's always the one that's got the
app like a top top-end new technology
and it's a video of what is presumably
it looks like an Arabian guy driving
driving down the street and it's just
him in the backseat with no one else in
the car going its feet across the center
console with his socks on reading as the
car just drives it so that's the funny
dreams that isn't it bit like him so
like all of the benefits of public
transport yeah exactly but with neither
sound run tire I'll be amazing
great yeah I think our hope is it
protected BP oh my god is it bigger was
it it was take away any problem with our
like I want to live closer to work or
whatever because it suddenly makes you
commute so comfortable amazing you know
you do anything in the drive can't you
sleep longer I you know yeah my brush
your teeth you could bring a little bath
bag and like continue doing the morning
routine but the argument would be to get
like for transit but that does that and
then kick the back out as just as a half
a room in your house transit work that's
fully oh my god or even the Chapmans I
don't care like other ones were with
cheapest yeah the best yield right let's
do a quick fire round
okay round ones so Anki for me oh that's
what you used to study with the med
school right yeah well remembered so
it's a spaced repetition of software
based on a lot of the evidence showing
that the act of actively remembering
something the act of recall is the thing
which cements in memories not repeated
exposure but it's repeated retrieval and
so unki helped me to perform quite well
in my exams a couple of years ago in med
school the last year and didn't really
use it as much unfortunately but that
was just cuz I was being lazy and over
overstretched but I made six thousand
flashcards and just reviewed them and it
gives you analytics and so you reviewed
each of them maybe three or four times
over and by that point you're pretty
familiar with the material I think for
anyone asked to memorize a large amount
of information in a short time it's
probably the best way to actively cement
it and you can use this you create your
own cards and then you quizzes you on
the card so you can made you can create
your own or there are I mean for
something like medicine where it's quite
unanimous topic like that yeah and if
you pick which is known as rules right
yeah so so know the people have made
decks themselves which is electron free
so that's
[ __ ] good resource yeah they gonna
guess like for learning stuff like
languages and things like that maybe no
there's loads of parts for languages
have a reviewed they're not but you can
you can usually tell like I said that
this is one could flush finals which is
like split into you know cardiology
neurology endocrinology and stuff and
it's all like they give you sources at
the end of you whoever's making
flashcards as knows what they're doing
yeah just quite an insidious thing isn't
it like if you made the flashcards and
right wrong like slightly wrong yeah
it's why I don't always want our ally on
people's decks cuz yeah well like boy
this person yeah you're assuming then
they've just copied out a textbook or
yeah that's pretty pretty [ __ ] cool
though and he does a mobile app yes
it'll be a mobile apps 20 pounds for
iPhone but I you know what I was like
I'm paying nine grand for my if you've
paid twenty pounds for a mobile app
there is no greater accolade in this if
he's paid for app it's just gonna
straight away I don't know what I'm not
even studying medicine or anything so
it's like well if you got to enjoy it
further the one redeeming thing of
having an Android is that it's free yeah
develop apps in the front row yeah so a
new I think it's a bit more open source
Johnny if you got one green smoothies no
never said that no no you pick one this
morning Rosie and cooked it so I find
just generally like vegetables and fruit
and like managing my like the quality of
my diet better pain generator
well aware that it's something like
everyone feels like they should probably
have more food but it was like even like
a very thick be of a flexible value
community even vegans probably yeah
everyone's like actually probably do
with having more free emotional I don't
know anyone that's like I I'm having you
know any vegetable yeah precisely really
cut down my vegetable intake so like I
just don't like it being something like
the end of the day if you like how many
vegetables to these things are like
peppers yeah how can I fudge it in this
and so instead just breakfast for me is
green smoothie what just what goes into
it means me spinach Leary's banana let's
keep it brief
and I add like my bike creatine and
stuff like that so take all my
supplements so there's like a reasonable
hit of micro nutrition and like all of
the like health stuff that I feel like I
should do it's done
what blender would you recommend I don't
know really mutters I think what you use
it's a room in the brand not like a new
triple no it's a joke on a stand it's
like an old-school you one yeah yeah I
think like you don't my dad's got a
nutribullet where other guys
I think they is that one way you clip it
in and it's the cups 34 so yeah if
trouble with that so does not detach as
a philosophy you can carry you know
you're on the troll with them is the
sometimes so often the special fusing
protein powder the it expands and
because it's sealed when you put it on
he's gonna take it off it oh yeah okay
so did you go anywheres front recipes
yeah so you put how much spinach turn
drums yeah no sir okay so you so maybe
it isn't tuna ground but it's a lot it's
a lot of spinach like it's not my kid
I like a pincher but much it's like I'm
talking that thick end of a linear bag a
tree if how all of you probably frozen
optimized the stock management so weekly
shop weekly shop you get don't buy
frozen spinach that is so important I
cannot repeat that enough you tell me
this story why not so that because no it
comes in like little hooks like a hockey
puck okay so you get a bag of frozen
spinach juice and loads of a hockey puck
to spinach in it but I'll be fine throw
those in first go on the blender is like
oh my god what's gonna happen here is
FaceTime unique panic turn off okay
check
happened okay I'll just leave it
I've still got anxiety about leaving the
blender it's even down to the stuff that
you do when I go in the house myself
slowly move away from like you would do
with the dog that's been yeah ste yeah
so like so what I'll normally date while
I make my breakfast coffee green
smoothie so even now this morning but
everything in press go there's been a
few instances where I've liked your bit
tired you're like for stuff in slightly
miss miss like get the quantities wrong
and it goes it starts flowing over the
thing so like you just press go and I'll
get my coffee you're making it one bit
just looking at it so guess something
are you making your coffee on the side
of the room it's fine every morning so
yeah pokes of spinach and plus they
don't blend so you're drinking it and
suddenly you get hit with a pop of
spinach
there's pot still frozen then it's
million okay this is so bad so buy fresh
make that mistake before and it's bad
it's just not worth it it's not it's not
more cost-efficient or anything it's
just worse by so even like end of line
spinach fresh spinach freeze it that
seems you get home yeah and it's good
for and then you put it in frozen do you
not do from yeah yeah billion present so
for froze fresh spinach frozen goes very
flaky yeah secret you can compress it
yeah okay so you put it in and then I
with my fist push it down yeah
blueberries banana frozen blue preferred
presently refresh Bernardo
cuz I think you boy frozen spinach must
be partially boiled or something because
it's and pot and then like compressed
and it must be cut to get it into a pot
yeah shaping well cuz they're just going
for capacity in the bargain ownership so
okay so you throw all that it doesn't
taste it's not like the nicest thing in
the world Bates it's like it is
sufficiently palpable that you don't
yeah you don't you don't drink because
there's some food there and a bit of
operating body you don't drink anything
oh my god that's a spinach drink yeah
there's a slight taste of it but if you
look up it's quite refreshing it's quiet
yeah yeah yeah
but I just feel so clean what are the
money what are the reported benefits
coming from you fantastic one white
wonders honesty it is it turns your
pooing into a timetable event Wow
like my you could be more confident on
your pues then like the time the news
comes on like it on surge of the sermon
yeah now it's a yeah the tune of your
I'll move and there's something that
that Kelly Starrett said that I still
remember that he must have said it like
casually or five years ago which is if
everyday that obviously sony post a man
let's not get the gender thing it
applies to people with a functioning
penis now and so if you wake up every
day if you wake it with an erection and
you have a good poop you're probably
fine health-wise really like how simple
it is yeah and like there's probably
quite a bit of truth to it yep
so yeah just very if you greatly poo on
the Bristol pew scale like you're pretty
much exactly where you need right on the
money here like it's just a bunch of
fiber isn't it and it's a big like low
it's like doméstico in through your
systems yeah it's gonna flush the vote
yeah that's I'm gonna do it I'm gonna
try it you've bought me enough sort of
cooking I know I'm slow cooking now it's
also it's great for you because it's
it's really fast just really convenient
and like also you can once you've made
it you can just have it while you're
like getting this stuff ready hard yeah
which I can't be bothered with like
making breakfast in the morning yeah so
it's right my mall right with making
breakfast couldn't eat to eat but yeah
that's like put in a brain shaker take
it with you just washed it was it not a
joke do you not find because it's frozen
is it not like really [ __ ] cold not
as much as you think okay so remember we
used to make frozen blueberries in with
Greek yogurt and protein powder really
cool and it was actually freeze the
[ __ ] are eating them I think there's
something about whisky breaking it up
yeah yeah okay but like what's nice
about that combination is that's your
blank canvas
banana he would have had in mango papaya
you know so why he why he saddled with
those in green just because it's nice
and other quantities off the top my head
the other thing about it like it's not
expensive
reading minimal calories as well yeah
it's like 200 300 calories or something
it's not
I think there's mine your easel oh it's
gonna be yeah plus like buying a bag of
mango you could buy mango bongos as
denardi diced mango and pineapple
together really she's really good big
bottles and when you go and have a look
at some of the options for frozen fruit
and vegetables
unbelievably if you have taken it to
real exceeding by smoothie bugs it's
like you could own it will try to do I
look I've gotten there as my my shortcut
for slow cooking now is to buy
pre-prepped chopped 1 kilo bags of
vegetables it's the berries in there so
it makes pies I know yep and and this is
a probably a little bit tiny little bit
of some kind of marinade that they've
been throwing in soup mixes or whatever
yes a tiny little bit and then you throw
that in meat stock water pepper salt
cumin though mate Alice wake up the next
morning storage that's that's a full
day's eating and so if my final one is
one that I don't think I've even told
you to about although you may know vsco
cam oh yeah I've mentioned this to
uniformed vsco cam so isn't that the way
secrets I know I am well this is this is
a proper this is an actual proper life
hack so at the SCO is basically a photo
editing app it's free for all though
there's not great as with everything
together the super big dick version mmm
and it's kind of similar to Instagram
without the posting functionality so
you've got a bunch of preset filters on
there but the filters on there are
[ __ ] unbelievable so one of the ways
that I've managed to make a lot of the
screen grabs from podcasts
look really good isn't by going on
desktop and doing on Photoshop it's by
using b1 mmm Oh a to the to a fibers
okay five years a5 a5 on on the SEO and
it looks awesome
it just there's there's like a whole
hypebeast because of that it's like a
kind of like a website for supreme and
like super trendy three-way right they
released two exclusive filters through
the SEO and about once every month
there'll be a free one you can download
you just as long as you make sure you're
online and you're at a tea pack you end
up with this thing and you can do all
sorts of March it with it like you can
add grain the sharpness is a lot finer
and can also go higher a lot higher than
you can on Instagram so especially if
you're looking to create a brand if
you're doing any sort of Instagram or
tumblr or even so I guess your Facebook
and Twitter as well when you need to
spend a little bit of time making sure
that your pictures look perfect there's
a lot more customizer customizability
through this app that's all I tend to do
is go to the SEO throw a batch of
filters then you can batch export as
well
mmm put it through Instagram do the
final little tweaks and does it save
them in an Instagram dimension no so you
can you can drop to whatever you want
right but the best way they're always
the best way to do it is to export is
full size full aspect and then crop on
Instagram because if you crop it before
and then realize that you need to zoom
out you can't but if you export full
size and then grab it from that then
you've got as much of the image to play
with as you can and that's oh yeah the
SEO it's free it's on a App Store and
whatever you prove miss righteous effort
Android do you already have one Google
Play yes but I was gonna ask you why did
you say sorry thing that's just being
niggling mass today what else what I
will do and I imagine you're saying is I
would buy it because of the by the
exotic fruit in there yes I like you
would buy like rhubarb yeah and you pour
out your like right this is mainly like
mainly cucum melon with it with it a
little bit of so that they they under
provide on their like what is
the right more expensive friends you
think dried fruit yeah then they were
like miss shapen banana or like yeah
it's like what you're getting is just
frozen versions of regular like playin
fruit which it like is fair enough
I understand why they did it but they're
they're just doing it for people who
want to just the sole person he makes
makes like puts that plus like some
yogurt in it smooth making as in the
morning
I just think once once you've had like
the pips of a smoothie is not for like a
nice thing it's extremely notice of a
homemade smoothie yeah yeah because
innocent have just got that game on God
on what they say you cannot beat
innocent sometimes the taste and I've
tried yeah yeah they honor tropic honor
of just started venturing into the
smoothie market and I think they should
stick to you
orange juice with bitterness and just
great orange here but no I mean the
thing is it's all with innocent
smoothies you can go and I did you
remember when he came in before and in
my fridge there's like a cake service so
no it was like there's got two pounds on
one part 55 yeah I just came it and you
got right through me man that red one
yeah so yeah yeah there's your serve
decadent that you can't believe that
it's healthy
yeah because it's taste so intense when
that's what happened you in three years
time when you'd refine the exact amount
of spinach and I make [ __ ] yourself a
lab in an industrial estate yeah these
conical flasks everyone doing out the
back of an RV yeah did watch Breaking
Bad just finished it it was a stressful
experience what most people enjoy
why did you ask you fun well just cuz
crested a like an image branding one and
I imagine I like if you and I went into
the propane world there's so much [ __ ] I
said I was thinking there's I mean just
the stuff we use like this stuff that
makes they be like like propane tools
because I own all these are personal
tools of this
far yeah when you get this dissonance
when you're talking about how to
expedite like if I could do like you've
got loads on my Dungy Facebook plug-in I
could I could sit and do all right well
think it we'll do that another time
yeah like I think I think social media
I'm sitting down with you know so coming
up soon
I've got Johann Hari author of lost
connections I'm absolutely [ __ ] my
pants to sit down with him because he's
a [ __ ] like an absolute monster and
intellectual behemoth so I'm sitting up
then tomorrow I'm sitting down with
Corey Allen originally creator of
releasing to now authorizes lumen yeah
bring it in you running at you over
three moments so his voice I want to
find out if his voice actually sounds
like that if he puts I think it was the
guy's exactly is the hook cast no yeah I
wanted to know I wanted to not listen to
any of this stuff before I try to I've
been tempted to listen to it for ages
but that I knew is coming on so as I
write me a slice right so that's going
to be the first one in modern wisdom
that's actually been based around
meditation so I'm going to go from
beginning to deepening your practice and
try and find if there's some principles
for practice and some confirmed
adaptations that he thinks so we're
gonna find like no matter what level
you're going into meditation that you're
gonna you're gonna learn some [ __ ]
question and then him Johann Hari and
Tuesday this week hopefully I'm gonna
get print anak Jimmy not training
systems that allow me it's gonna be
unbelievable some of his videos are
fantastic the ones that he does about
it's gonna be hopefully I'm gonna try
and get him onto the line of thinking
about mobility myths so not only he
loves that stuff yes and he's just a de
psyched he's like a Mythbusters like new
bunker for everything to do he's like
anti stretching only foam rolling just
as that does you know how those people
do the 1990 hip thing he does it he does
a bunch of stuff he's not he's not
necessarily anti I think that he just
understands very well is his website
clinical awfully calm
so he just understands physiologically
what the adaptations are and how he can
best utilize them so you can learn about
mobility you gonna learn Johann Hari
lost connections like [ __ ] knows what
I'm gonna learn that like a written what
appears to be the seminal meta-analysis
on depression and anxiety for the modern
world
he's also Johann Harry's just as of
three weeks ago or four weeks ago taken
six months break from your social media
that'll be cool to learn about in the
airlin it so thank you very much you're
gonna end up doing that on you so you
kind of break now you kill me I can't
I'd love to I can't wait until the day
when I don't need to be on social media
but for as long as we have maybe about
day eleven for as long as we have an
event company that's not going to be
that's not going to be possible why
don't you pay me and you said no I'm not
sure that I think I think it would you
suppose wet rub it rub it like this what
do you just Amy's what you mean
if you had a set make it a manual of
Chris so is a good manual this is hardly
Chris make a Stephen manual of Chris and
then say like in these situations so if
X Y and the y is just tell me is there
like once a day pass it up the change
someone comes like someone comes I sites
it's their house like a Ovaltine yeah
and tells you this is one today so out
today Chris these hours to know how
would you lay how would you like to move
forward well then cause you on your life
though and on smartphones good during
office hours very this if you definitely
a key site it could be done it could
definitely be done it could be took it
would be the most interesting project
ever ever yeah ever final thought from
all of history and fall in the future
this would be that's quite prospects
like yeah we're gonna look do we're on
the cusp of that look at the youth what
a time to be alive wow it is right thank
you
we were supposed to talk about
relationships this evening
well you do have a did you think or were
you the last one
oh yeah unda doesn't do a thing with my
last okay to be honest I was it was unki
well cool that's cool yeah it was gonna
be slow cooking but youyou kind of
discussed that already so that will do
proper debrief and slow cooking next
I'll be good
I'm just made that cider chicken one how
was it always come up really good we'd
recommend would you oh yeah month that
don't that ever no I'm gonna make that
Evan up public that said recipes so that
one it's just business
reset like someone else's recipe convert
or three percent garbage our business
right okay bye Dan bye
[Music]